Numerous times in the last five years, Venezuelan
dictator
Nicolas Maduro has crushed pro-democracy demonstrations.
However, Venezuelans who are taking to the streets now to reclaim their freedom from a
narcodictatorship may finally have a fighting
chance.
The US and much of the international community
are backing Juan Guaidó
as the legitimate president of
Venezuela.
Democracies in the region have a great deal at stake in ensuring
a turnaround in Venezuela.
They should warn Maduro of dire consequences
if he uses violence against Guaidó
or other innocent civilians.
They also should recognize Guaidó’s authority
on all economic and diplomatic decisions.
The region and the United States should plan
to deliver humanitarian assistance the moment
President Guaidó and the National Assembly
authorize such operations on Venezuelan territory.
If there is a murderous crackdown against
demonstrators, these governments must be prepared
to protect human life from the regime.
Venezuela’s friends must continue to act
boldly to defend economic and political freedom in that country.
How do you think we should react to events in Venezuela?
Let us know in your comments. Also, let us know what other topics you'd like our scholars
to cover in 60 seconds, and be sure to like and subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.